this is pointless the ticker isn't even
going up
and everyone's giving me the stink eye i
don't know
everyone hates you i'll fork you too
that awful human being is
ingrid de forest she's a city councillor
from eagleton
she thinks she's so great because she
won the miss indiana beauty pageant
last year while she was in office and
pregnant
as always we would like to make a
friendly wager with eagleton
if you beat us this year we will give
you a basket of apples
from our pawnee orchard pesticide yuck
oh no these are pesticide free i ate one
of these for breakfast this morning and
i found a worm in it
so i bet somebody feels pretty stupid
right now
well leslie i think we had similar ideas
if you win eagleton will give you this
basket of
oranges of course it's silly to compare
apples and oranges but
what the heck these are made of
swarovski crystal and they're worth
seven hundred thousand dollars leslie uh
you're down 15 points in the latest poll
for the recall election
what can you do to make up the deficit
i'll tell you what i'd do if i was an
eagletonian
i'd pop a xanax and ask my butler to
help me out
i mean i'm not saying that eagletonians
are out of touch but
when you tell them it's time to change
their oil they ask extra virgin or white
truffle
thanks guys i'll see you at the game
unless of course you're an eagle tony
and then you'll be too busy polishing
your monocle at the caviar store
nope out
are you sure this isn't you yeah man i'm
pretty sure i wasn't a death row lawyer
who collected clown paintings and
rescued orphans they got my name right
but nothing else
i mean somebody royally forked up
somebody forked up why can't i say fork
if you're trying to curse you can't hear
i guess a lot of people in this
neighborhood don't like it so it's
prohibited that's [ __ ]
it really is a pleasure to see you in
this context anchored
say cheese damn it you look beautiful
can you give us a little more
information surrounding the deficits
that you're running this year
oh gosh we don't really like to talk
about
money we find it a little gauche this is
a budget meeting
well most of our files are in these
boxes if you really want to take a look
at how much
that we've spent why don't we just dig
in and see what we're up against yes
and thank you we really appreciate your
help
are you tipping me is that 100
euros hey guys okay eleanor reminder we
switched to a rotating system for
choosing a designated driver and it's
your turn
got it full disclosure i forgot we were
doing this new system i got off work
early i've been here for about an
hour and i'm already pretty drunk
someone else will do it
good call guess the only place i'll be
driving is through the giant loophole in
the system i
accidentally discovered
just water tonight huh designated driver
yeah
it sucks i think it's awesome i mean
someone's got to do it right
i think it's a cool thing to do for
people yeah no
no i meant i meant i it sucks that i
can't do it
more often you know i actually prefer it
to drinking
staying sober knowing my friends will
get home safe
that's my buzz
hey guys good news and bad news see that
hot bartender over there
he's into me and we're gonna bang it out
the bad news is it means i can't drive
you guys home
but i did call a cab for you guys but
they recognized my number and they
didn't want to come i've thrown up in a
lot of cabs
so are we good here eleanor you have a
very important choice to make
if you blow us off you are banned from
thursday night drinks
forever
yeah i'm good with that i'll see you
guys at work peace
you let's go think fast
oh why do people keep assuming i'm ready
to catch things
eagleton no money no problems fantastic
right
i made enough of them for everybody to
wear at the game i do like a good
internal rhyme ben you ready for dinner
we can go over the poll numbers oh you
know
i've got a few phone calls to make can
you give me an hour
i can meet you there oh my god
what is she doing here sorry leslie but
you didn't really help them very much so
we volunteered to give them a little
financial advice you didn't actually
help us at all
just one second i'm just gonna help them
out
okay just for an hour he's just being a
good neighbor
we're in a lot of trouble leslie i don't
need any lip from you okay you're in
trouble because of your own stupidity
i have a phd from the sorbonne for what
wearing chanel suits there was a fashion
component yes
i'm not mad that you're doing this yes i
am mad that you're doing this
but even worse i'm mad that you just
lied to me about it i'm sorry we all
swore that we weren't gonna ever help
her again ever
i never said that you did i speak for
all of us in all matters
that is what you tacitly agreed to when
you married me what yeah let's go
you've changed your mind you're not
gonna help her anymore i just want to
borrow your husband for the evening
so all i want to do is just check in see
how everyone's holding up just bring
some cheer to these extraordinary people
cool so tell me about yourself
i mean i want to hear it all girlfriend
the good the bad the
really bad the embarrassing the
humiliating just
let's bond okay well i i was born in
pakistan
raised in london schooled in paris but i
think the primary reason i'm in the good
place is that
i raised quite a lot of money for
non-profit groups oh
did you ever uh skim a little off the
top for yourself
gracious no no every penny was accounted
for
and as i raised nearly 60 billion
dollars quite a lot of pennies
but i also dabbled in some other
professions i i was a model
a museum curator and it girl and
oh i was basilarman's muse for a while
that was quite fun modeling
that's a crazy life want to tell me
about that rock bottom you probably
heard
i didn't really do it for long couture
just doesn't fit my body i'm cursed with
ample bosom
and yet you sold iran oh this is silly
so tahani
means congratulations in arabic and al
jamail means beautiful so my full name
all together
congratulations beautiful thanks senator
a big flirt
oh my god that was epic i was peeing so
freaking hard it was like a jacuzzi
jetter hi leslie hey
ingrid i i wasn't talking about the
velocity of my pee because you are a
very smart and
classy lady man you remember ingrid de
forest from the former eagleton
yeah she was just telling me she's been
nominated to run against you in the
recall
wow buzzkill i know you must hate me
right now leslie
and and that's justified but i need to
thank you for what you just did in there
not the forceful urination the
filibuster right yeah
it was incredibly courageous and it was
selfless
and if i do win i'm gonna have very big
roller skates to fill
could i take you out for a celebratory
plate of i think you call them waffles
wow that is the best offer you could
ever make but i had to miss my husband's
birthday party for this so
i think i'll be spending the evening
with him a raincheck maybe please
i'm sorry your birthday party got all
screwed up
maybe i should put those roller skates
back on well you must be exhausted we
don't have to go to the party no we're
not going to the party
we're going home then why would you need
to put on roller skates
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah we're just
we just skated is a key subject for a
lot
of great thinkers in the dal tejing lao
tzu wrote
knowing others is wisdom
but knowing the self is enlightenment ah
knowing yourself is he talking about
what i think he's talking about
no eleanor once again none of these
philosophers
is ever talking about masturbation let's
uh move on to
this week's main event david humes a
treatise of human nature you read this
right
i did well i tried to well i tried to
want to
um actually could we postpone this
lesson i've befriended jianyu from next
door and i thought
i could learn from him that's a great
idea hume's bundle theory of the self is
fairly close to buddhism yeah no durr
that's why i'm doing it
do you hear music that's not music
that's edm
[Applause]
what are you doing eleanor you were
right no more pretending
it's time for me to be myself what's up
homie
eleanor you broke john you
this must be hard for you it's like what
serene mckellen said to me the day i
sold my boat to carl lagerfeld
parting is such sweet sorrow oh my god
what is your life
if it makes any difference your work
here was a real inspiration to me and i
am going to do my best to continue your
legacy
well i appreciate the sentiment
leslie i'm sorry was i singing goodbye
yellow brick road out loud
no would you like to i studied opera at
the sarbone i'd be happy to harmonize
you